Optimal at this altitude,
I can run flat out for a half mile before my hands start shaking.
I know.
How else are you posting a question?
This episode is brought to you by helix sleep.
Last year I committed to making sleep a top priority,
trying to fix onset insomnia or continuing to fix that depth of sleep,
quality of sleep.
I tracked a lot.
I tested a lot and I revisited really everything from the daily routine to the
surface as I slept on playing with the chilly pad,
whatever.
And when I moved to Austin I got all new beds,
including mattresses from Helix,
working with the world's leading sleep experts.
Certainly some of them.
He looks sleep developed mattresses personalized to your preferences and sleep
style to make sure that you can have the best sleep possible without costing
thousands upon thousands of dollars.
He looks sleep has recently added a new layer to customize sleep with the helix
pillow.
The all new pillows are fully adjustable so you can achieve perfect comfort
regardless of sleep position or body type or if you're a shifty type like me.
I move around quite a bit when I sleep.
Just take their simple two to three minute sleep quiz to get started and that
will help ensure that they can build a mattress or pillow that you will love the
mattress,
whatever this be spoke,
mattresses that you arrive at a we'll get to you within a week and the shipping
is completely free.
You can try the mattress for 100 nights and if you're not completely happy,
they'll pick it up and offer a full refund.
I tested that refund policy because I test all of these sponsors and kick the
tires a lot.
We tested it and they came through and making sure that we got ultimately the
right mattress for my body.
Type to personalize your sleep experience,
visit Helix,
sleep.com forward slash Tim and you'll receive up to $125 off your mattress
order.
That's helix sleep,
h,
e l I x sleep.com forward slash Tim for up to $125 off your order.
This episode is brought to you by business wars.
People always ask me what podcasts I listened to and the truth is not many
because given all my other projects,
I don't have a ton of extra bandwidth,
but one new addition is business wars from the podcast network.
Wondery human history has seen hundreds upon hundreds of epic wars of course,
and often they're between nations,
but some wars are waged between large corporations are between startups and
large incumbents,
business wars,
which had been listening to teach you right into the middle of these battles
that are waged for control of your wallet and your attention ranging from say
the wars between Netflix and blockbuster or a Nike and Adidas,
two rivals and small businesses across the country struggling to survive in a
cutthroat world.
These stories really feel like dramatic.
I've been very impressed by the sound design also,
which I didn't think I would care about,
but it makes a huge,
huge difference.
And just to give you an idea of what you might discover,
did you know that blockbuster was actually catching up with Netflix until
corporate raider?
Carl ICAHN got involved and that episode is a fantastic one.
It's called sudden death.
It's the first episode in a multipart series that looks at blockbuster and
Netflix,
which I'm particularly interested in because it's not just two businesses in a
stagnant industry with stagnant technology.
There's a lot of different factors that come into play,
or did you know,
or do you know what marvel did to really get ahead of,
it's a much larger competitor,
DC comics of great interest to me since I was a comic book nerd and collected
comics when I was a kid or how sneakers went from athletic wear to everyday,
where this series explores all of that and more.
It's hosted by David Brown,
a former anchor of marketplace,
and it is an immersive sound design experience,
not just some type of sterile business review that shares the untold and very
real stories of what went on behind the scenes with the leaders,
investors,
executives that led them to either new heights or to ruin.
Sometimes somewhere in between.
You can search for business wars on apple podcasts or wherever you're listening
to this episode right now or had to wondery.fm Ford Slash Tim that's w o n d e r
y.fm forward slash Tim to find business where it's a great show and I do not say
that lightly and I might suggest start with sudden death,
Netflix versus blockbuster.
Hello Ladies and gentlemen,
this is Tim Ferriss and welcome to another episode of the Tim Ferriss show.
My job is usually to deconstruct world class performers from different
industries and sectors,
military entertainment,
business and so on to tease out habits and routines from people who have made
seemingly all of the right decisions.
This episode is very different and my hope is that it still provides learning
lessons and takeaways and helps you also to develop skills like empathy.
This came about because I interviewed a woman named cat hoke on this podcast.
She is the founder of something called defy ventures,
which uses entrepreneurship and job training to reduce recidivism among a prison
populations and she creates what she would call entrepreneurs in training e I
t's and inmates.
If you want to call them that are encouraged to use this as a new label for self
identification and it's been very,
very successful.
When I spoke to her on this podcast,
I promised that I would visit a prison with her and that's exactly what I ended
up doing.
Several weeks ago I visited a maximum security prison to experience the program
that she started.
I struggled with trying to do this and production several times so I'm just
going to run with it and it's going to perhaps bounce around a bit.
It was a very,
very emotional trip and I thought I would actually borrow from my friend Dr
Peter Tia who also attended,
uh,
and recruited a number of people to go alongside him and he sent this out to his
newsletter and a,
I'm going to a bridge a little bit this week.
Tim Ferriss and I recruited a few friends to visit current state prison KRN
level four I he max security prison in California and the background then goes
into how to five inches is done work inside prisons like current in Pelican Bay.
He goes on to say,
cat is one of the most remarkable souls on this planet and nothing could prepare
me for what we experienced at Kern this week.
Rather than try to explain it in an email,
eventually discuss this in depth on a podcast,
and these are Peter's words.
Again,
many of the men came up to us as we were leaving with tears in their eyes to
thank us for coming to express their gratitude for the little bit we did.
What I don't think they will ever understand is that they gave us infinitely
more than we can give them.
I can not explain with words what it feels like to embrace a 32 year old man
who's been incarcerated since he was 13 in solitary confinement for 12 of those
years and admit our most shameful moments in life to each other.
So some of you might be listening to this back to Tim now and wondering what the
hell is Tim talking about?
And I'm going to use a statistic that I've heard several times.
Someone out there can fact check this,
but I believe it's accurate,
which is roughly 70% of people released from maximum security prisons are back
in prison within five years.
And,
uh,
this underscores a number of weaknesses and issues with number of societal
systems that we've put in place.
But suffice to say,
many of the people who are even convicted of murder are going to be released.
They're going to be your neighbors and there is a choice then rather than just
brushing it aside with,
they should just lock them up and throw away the key.
Since that's not going to be the case for many folks,
there's a question of whether you want people to be rehabilitated or not,
which type of neighbor having just come out of prison?
Do you want to have?
And uh,
there's,
there's much more nuance to it.
But that's one helpful at the lead into it.
And I began looking at programs with good results and unique approaches to
helping to fundamentally change how people view themselves and the world.
Uh,
and that is part of what I try to do.
And I learned so much at Kern that,
uh,
I want it to dig into it with this podcast,
but also to share with you the,
the footage,
the video footage that I recorded from the rare opportunity to actually sit down
with three men on the inside and to talk to them about the mistakes they'd made
when they turn things around,
what they've done when they slip up and so on.
And it applies to much more than people in prison are people who have committed
homicide or armed robbery.
I think it applies to everybody.
Uh,
so I wanted to really paint a picture of the humanity in people who have done
terrible things,
no doubt about it.
They have suffered the consequences per the rules that we have in the societies
that we've built and are now attempting and changing their trajectories.
And we all have these different points in life when it's important to change
direction.
So I always special thanks first and foremost to all the staff and officers
occur and including Chief Deputy Warren Goss who helped set up the interview.
Keeping in mind,
I couldn't even bring in an alligator clip because to hold pieces of paper
together because those can be fashioned into tools for cutting through doors.
I'm not making this up.
So to have the ability to walk in with cables and recorders and all of this was
really,
really incredible and unique.
I,
I again,
I knew I was going to struggle with this intro,
but I'm never going to get it quite right and I wanted to at least explain one
exercise we did was,
we'll come back to Peter's words that was so incredibly powerful,
uh,
speaking to a number of the volunteers like me who are there to help as mentors,
listening to different pitches for new businesses and so on that these men hope
to launch when they get out of prison to sustain them.
The vast majority of volunteers I spoke with said it was one of the most
emotionally powerful experiences of their entire lives.
And,
uh,
I'm going to quote from a fast company piece that covered defy,
and describes an exercise called stepped to the line,
which if you have the opportunity to experience,
I highly,
highly recommend,
I cannot recommend it highly enough.
In fact.
So here we go.
I'm quoting from the piece.
The idea is this,
remember exercise step to the line hoke.
That's cat reads from a list of statements.
And if they ring true to any of the its I e the inmates or volunteers,
they stepped forward to the line.
And so there are two lines of tape on the ground about say 18 inches apart and
they run for 20 to 30 feet,
maybe more because you could have say 50 to 100 EIT is and similar number of
volunteers.
All right,
back to the piece.
She'll eventually read several dozen of the statements and the group that's
steps to the line each time is different.
Or this piece took a place or was reported at Pelican Bay.
Uh,
I'm going to cut some of it up.
So she begins with statements designed to loosen folks up.
I was a class clown.
People step forward or not.
I'm madly in love.
I madly in love with Burritos.
Hahaha.
So people loosen up and this is important in any type of extras or interview.
Then she moves on to the harder stuff.
I've had my heart broken.
Again,
this is from a fast company piece.
Everyone in the room steps to the line except one EIT.
I dropped out of high school.
Almost every EIT steps forward with just one of the volunteers.
I've been in a fight to prove myself all,
but three of the EIT is move forward and then it's time for the really deep
stuff.
I grew up in poverty.
My mom or dad has been to prison,
at least one of my parents abused drugs or alcohol.
I was born to a teenage mother.
I became a teenage parent myself.
These are all separate questions and people step to the line or step back from
the line.
Uh,
and,
and pulling back just for a second to my experience or other questions that
really were a kind of a donkey kick to the psyche because they were
considerations I'd never made before.
Uh,
such as,
and I'm paraphrasing here,
but I grew up in a home with fewer than 25 books out of the volunteers.
Everyone stepped forward to the line of the EIT is two or three,
right?
All right,
back to the piece watching Hook and the EIT is you begin to understand the life
stories of the people in the room just by how many steps align or how many did.
So again,
and again,
my parents talked me into bed and told me I was loved.
A few of the it step forward,
violence took place in my home growing up,
violence took place against me growing up.
Uh,
when I was 18,
I thought I wouldn't make it to 21 and it goes on and on.
Not forgiving others is hurting me and almost everybody is going to step
forward.
At least during my experience.
That was the case.
And there are others such as have you ever sat behind the wheel of the car while
feeling the effects of alcohol?
Almost everybody's going to step forward.
And then I have been convicted of a driving while drunk,
uh,
and so on and so forth.
And then you see how circumstances,
certainly freewill and bad decision,
but also circumstances have led us all to where we are.
And that doesn't absolve anybody in prison of the things that they did.
But it does give you an appreciation for how things could have turned out
differently,
had a handful of circumstances,
had been different,
uh,
for even the volunteers.
And I know this intro is running long,
please bear with me.
Uh,
so this interview,
talking with these three men was really a profound experience for me.
And you can see the hope in these men that is created when they have an
opportunity to rebuild and redefine themselves.
Uh,
I was very,
very impressed and surprised,
uh,
by a lot of what I saw,
some incredible artwork,
uh,
and some incredibly well spoken people.
And when they take ownership of their pasts and are going to be getting out of
prison,
the question comes back to you yet again.
Who Do you want back in society?
A rehabilitated person or not?
I'm going to mention two more things and we're going to jump into the interview.
If people want to go to prison and have this type of experience,
cat is still bringing people and now has five more prison trips lined up.
You can email admin at [inaudible] dot com c a t h o k e.com.
If interested,
there are also other groups doing this type of work and make an impact like the
anti-recidivism coalition arc.
You can find that at anti-recidivism dot org uh,
and I wanted to just mention one more thing and this was sent to me,
which is quite difficult through a,
I'm imagining two or three different intermediaries,
uh,
by one of the men who I interviewed for this podcast.
And it was a followup on one of the questions that I had sent.
So this is a message from Jason who was interviewed and uh,
this is what he sent through the proper channels to get to me quote.
During the interview,
Tim asked us a very important question that we feel was perhaps the most
important one of all.
He asked how we handle setbacks or slip ups.
And what we tell people who make mistakes along the way.
I felt like this was something that merited at least reaching out for.
If there's a way to include this,
that would be cool.
If not,
I tried.
It is unrealistic to think that a person could make drastic changes in their
life and charter new trajectory and then execute without failure.
Two steps forward.
One step back is not uncommon to that.
I've told others and still say that the key lies in not allowing oneself to
become discouraged to the point of a total regression.
Note the failure simply as a result that didn't get you to your objective and
then tweak your strategy accordingly.
Try,
try again.
It is often stated that those who are most successful in life are also really
good at dealing with failure.
We should use them as role models and view it as they do.
It's simply feedback that we can use to discern how our plan is working.
This is easier said than done,
but it's been done many times over.
Good luck and take heart because the best is yet to come.
So this is what Jason would say to someone who has back slit.
And that could be say you're trying to lose weight and then you end up eating a
box of cookies.
It could be that you quit smoking and you have a few drinks and much to your
later regret and shame that you pick up a cigarette could be any number of
things.
Uh,
but you'll find a lot of shared humanity in this conversation.
And there are few quick notes.
The shoe is solitary confinement.
We initially only had 20 minutes allowed for this and then there was a bus
malfunction for another group arriving.
So I was able to stretch it out quite a bit.
I also realized after the fact that I shouldn't have asked about specific gang
names because there can be violent consequences.
Uh,
so I bleeped out one mention of that and with that very,
very long introduction out of the way.
Thank you guys for the patients.
Please enjoy this conversation.
A very rare opportunity behind the wall in a maximum security prison to chat
with three men about their life stories.
All right guys.
So we're sitting here in the,
is this the visitation center sit in that?
Uh,
it looks like,
uh,
like I say a half circle table and it's my first time in a prison.
We are in a maximum security prison.
And I was hoping maybe we could start,
I know time is short.
Just on a quick round of introductions,
just one at a time saying name.
It could be first name,
full name and where you're from and how you ended up in prison.
Uh,
my name is,
uh,
Jason Holland.
I'm 41 years old.
Uh,
when I was a teenager I was living a reckless life,
misguided youth,
or actually I
should say wayward youth because I have to take responsibility for my actions.
But,
um,
I was making some decisions that clearly weren't good in my life and eventually
it,
it resulted in me taking someone's life.
And at 19,
I was sentenced to life without parole for a felony murder.
And I've been in prison ever since.
Thank you.
Yes sir.
Tim,
welcome to prison.
Thank you.
My name is [inaudible].
I'm 37 years old.
I've been incarcerated for the past 10 years.
Uh,
I am,
uh,
serving a sentence for two counts of armed robbery,
firearm deadly weapon.
Uh,
unfortunately I went through a really bad divorce in 2006.
I think that was perhaps the,
the significant event that kind of led me here.
Um,
I didn't cope well.
In fact,
I made all the right wrong decisions and,
uh,
I,
made some very poor choices.
Obviously I gravitated back to,
uh,
you know,
the crowd that I used to run with when I was much,
much younger.
And,
um,
I'm here now and,
uh,
trying to,
trying to try and make the best of a,
of who I am now.
Basically.
Uh,
my name is Brandon.
when I was 21,
I was incarcerated for murder.
I'm serving life without parole.
When I was younger,
I had some real issues,
socially reacting or interacting with people.
It caused me to sort of compartmentalize my life among groups of people.
And it took an enormous amount of emotional energy to ups,
uh,
hope,
hold that.
And as it started to fall apart and I became desperate to latch onto these
people,
that led me to make some really,
really bad choices.
And as a result,
I've been incarcerated for the last 13 years in May.
Thank you guys.
So I mean,
the question really in my mind as I'm getting educated here,
it's my first time,
like I mentioned kind of on the other side of the walls,
uh,
is what,
what were the,
the moments or the conversations that led you guys to want to start building in
a different direction?
Right?
Because there are a lot of people here don't choose to change the path,
right?
And uh,
there's just recently some violence here and I understand the politics instead
of gang orders and so on here,
uh,
can be really complex.
I don't even pretend to understand it,
but like in,
in,
in your cases you've chosen to try to build in a different direction.
So maybe we could just go it,
whoever wants to go first could just let me know what,
catalyze that.
Okay.
That's a very good question.
Um,
I had been incarcerated for about 19 years.
I was validated in issue as a shoe is the SST lockdown units,
a security housing unit.
Right.
And I was validated as a prison gang associate.
At that point I was housed in a deep seg section.
What gang were you part of?
A,
I was associated with and
in prison in this world
I had a lot of prestige.
I had a lot of power and after 19 years I was sending in their shoe and I
realized even though I had this much prestige and this much power,
I was living an empty life.
It was meaningless.
That was isolation.
Where you by yourself?
Yes,
I was by myself at that point and
one day a friend came to me and he was telling me about changes that were
happening in the law and he said,
look,
if you ever want to get out of the shoe,
you need to start making some decisions.
And I didn't want to take ownership of my life at the time.
And so I was arguing with them.
I was blaming everyone else.
And then he said something that I couldn't argue with.
He said,
look,
whether you realize it or not to your own decisions or decisions that you've
allowed people to make for you,
you put yourself in a box.
And at that point,
I couldn't argue with that.
And so I had to come to terms with that and I had to start making some real
decisions.
And that was a big moment for me.
And that was a friend on the inside here?
No,
that was actually a friend from the outside.
Yes.
And uh,
he kind of hit it.
He hit me with the hard truth and then I started realizing what do I want from
my life,
where I started asking myself to a strong questions and I had to start making
some strong decisions.
And from there it's been a path of growth.
What were,
what were some of the first or the first kind of decision that you made that was
different from how you would've made decisions in the past?
Well,
first I had to start taking responsibility.
I had to start realizing that I was the one that was creating my circumstances.
It was no one else.
And then if I wanted to change things in my life,
what were the decisions I had to make?
And so the first thing I needed to do was just get away from what I had been
accepted for myself,
and that's been involved with gangs and criminal activities.
And so once I disassociated and left and it was from there,
what do I do now?
But it was just a matter of reconstructing my identity and finding new values.
And at that point,
when you left the gang,
you then move from one section of,
was it at this prison?
No,
it was a different prison.
Didn't Corkran.
Got It.
And where you then you were moved to a different location within the prison,
or was this to a different unit for people that were going through that process?
Got It.
Yes,
sir.
Uh,
for me,
uh,
God,
what I guess what I can,
I can start in 2013,
uh,
back then I was a member of a prison gang here.
Um,
and for the most part,
you know,
I've,
throughout my prison career,
as we call it,
uh,
assimilated completely the,
my environment.
I,
um,
which gang was that?
I'd rather not say.
Yeah.
Okay.
Well fine and I can take it out later.
It's,
um,
I was part of the problem here.
Yep.
Clearly.
And I remember,
I think the moment that Kinda changed everything changed for me was,
uh,
I was assigned to education and that education,
just regular ab one 82 83 just regular adult basic education.
I was,
I was assigned there so that I can eventually earn my GED.
Yup.
And I,
you know,
was sitting in the back doing all things that I shouldn't be doing with the
homies and I just,
I feel tired.
I got tired of it and I just didn't want to be there anymore.
I,
uh,
had two ways of going about it to get out of education.
At least that's what I thought at the time.
There was actually a third way I decided to just take the GED test and that way
I would be able to get out of there.
And that's exactly what I did.
I took the GED test and I passed it.
I,
uh,
showed up about two months later,
I got called up to receive my certificate and we'll,
I was standing in line waiting to get my certificate.
Somebody who was ahead of me made a comment about,
uh,
you know,
now going to college because,
now he was,
he had a GED.
He was a high school graduate and he was going to go to college.
But the way that he said he was being sarcastic,
but he said in a way where someone in the room turned around and looked at them
with like this look of disgust,
disbelief.
And it just so happened that at that precise moment he turned and looked at me
and I caught the full force of that look at that discussed.
And it angered me because back then my mentality was completely different.
And I kind of set out to prove from that point forward that,
you know what,
look at me,
how you want to look at me,
but I'm going to prove to you that even a gang member,
even someone like me,
can get a college education back then.
Uh,
the college programs were very,
very scarce.
Uh,
it took a moment for me to,
it took a little while for me to even find,
you know,
the,
the college coordinator on the facility.
And I wrote a couple of community colleges.
Eventually there,
they wrote back,
I got it,
I got it.
I got into,
uh,
into lasting community college up north.
And I started taking correspondence courses.
And so here I am,
I'm sitting in a housing unit filled with all my homeys because here in this
facility,
the house,
all the gang members together,
uh,
just to kind of control the violence on the yard.
And you know,
after the first year here I am,
you know,
knee deep in,
in college work,
studying sociology,
psychology,
philosophy and just,
you know,
really taking it on.
And the one day I just kind of looked up and I realized I don't belong here.
I was completely out of place,
meaning in the gang and bars in the gang environment.
And you know,
for the first time I was able to kind of see the world through a clear lens.
So for me it was definitely education and that was five years,
five years now.
And uh,
I've earned several college degrees.
Uh,
and,
you know,
it's,
I can honestly say that education truly transformed me.
Uh,
I was still stuck there and it took someone in the administration to give me an
opportunity to change,
to really make that transition into who I wanted to be.
A associate warden Goss,
who's a at the time was the captain on our facility.
Uh,
he gave me that opportunity.
So it wasn't just me wanting to,
I needed help.
And fortunately I was able to find that here.
And,
uh,
you know,
I've,
it's been a sprint since and I haven't stopped.
Thank you.
Well,
so I'm kind of the odd man out and a lot of ways.
All right.
So I was never in a gang.
Uh,
I came in and I was the guy who was going to be used up on the main line.
I was the guy they were going to give the knife and say,
Hey,
go get that guy.
What is used up on the mainland side pretty much means that I was expected to do
the dirty work as it needed to be done.
And then when I was caught up and washed up and done and done in or whatever,
nobody was going to really worry about it too much because I wasn't in the mix.
You know,
I wasn't in that whole politic side,
so I did that exactly once.
Um,
what does it,
could you just elaborate on what that means?
So guy came up to me on the yard and he basically said,
hey,
this guy,
we need to jump on him because he owes money.
And I tried to get out of it,
but I really didn't have a lot of options because they said,
we're doing this in about two minutes.
I got it.
And you're like a free agent.
I was a,
I was not a free agent.
I always associated held in the matter.
Well,
yeah,
I was,
I was a free agent who was told you're going to do this.
So I did it.
It was,
it was cowardly.
I hate it.
Right.
But I did it and I ended up in doing a shu term like Jason,
but much shorter,
right?
And eat in here.
I got out,
I came to another law mainline yard and they asked me to do it again and I said,
no,
we're not doing that.
So they jumped on me instead.
So that was fun.
Uh,
I came over here a two s and why that's the,
uh,
when you're not associating with the mainline politics.
So I just kind of figured out what fly under the radar.
I was just going to do my own thing on my own by myself.
And slowly but surely just started to get into a couple of things,
get talked to certain people work.
Uh,
I wrote an article for our newsletter,
things like that.
And it eventually led to me getting offered a job in the chapel,
which if you'd had told me when I was say 21 that I'd be working in a chapel of
the answer would have been zero because I was 21 and knew everything and was
this militant atheist and blah,
blah,
blah.
So the idea was absolutely unheard of.
But I was really desperate for something.
I needed to have something to do.
So I took the job and I remember having a conversation with my boss,
a chaplain Krantz or shout out to the,
you know,
the chaplain and he sits me down and he basically says,
so tell me,
tell me about how you look at things.
So I gave him this really profound,
like 30 minute conversation about how I knew everything and everything was
relative and this and that,
and I might be paraphrasing this,
but he basically sits back and he goes,
wow,
that's really stupid.
And,
uh,
I reflected on that for a while and he started to systematically over the next
few months,
just like breakdown every stupid little belief I had and slowly but surely
started to turn me around.
So I give him a lot of credit,
uh,
for me,
kind of go and positive as it were and kept kept hospital.
Sure.
What were some of the new beliefs
that that ended up being most helpful to you?
The biggest,
the thing,
the biggest teaching that he gave me,
um,
was the theory of a teleology Tele Os,
right?
So all people have an inherent human dignity.
Everybody has a potential.
And if everybody has this dignity in this potential,
in everybody is valuable,
every human life is valuable,
we should treat them.
So,
uh,
so this was the basis of a morality that I never had.
Everything I thought was relative.
And if it's good for me,
it's good for me.
It's good for you,
it's good for you.
And that's a bunch of crap that doesn't work.
That leads to a very bad place.
So this whole concept now and really driving it home,
and it was,
it's been 16 months in the making so far.
But that for me has been the pivotal thing is just understanding concepts of
morality.
Going from an atheist to a guy who somewhat of an audit agnostic who
acknowledges there's a higher power but doesn't know what it is yet.
Uh,
so for me,
that's a huge shift.
And so I credit that to me getting into the things that I recognize as enforcing
morality or reinforcing human dignity and the idea that everybody is valuable.
Thank you.
I'd love to hear from you Jason.
Basically the same question.
I mean like how,
how has the way you looked at the world changed or what beliefs or habits have
really helped to keep you on a better path or to help you to feel like you're
building towards something?
Okay,
very good question.
Um,
so when I first left the shoe and I was going through this process of basically
reconstructing my identity because I had this persona before and now it's gone
right when you had status too.
Yeah,
I did.
And um,
so I come over here and I didn't really know what to do.
I started reinvesting in my education because I didn't know really what to do.
I started getting any of these groups.
And then what happened was I was really lucky.
I came to this yard and I met these guys and I started working around them and
then I started getting introduced to this,
some of the same ideas.
How did you guys meet dignity?
Well,
it was just kind of on the yard,
but they knew I was coming.
They knew that my,
um,
my brother and I were coming here and so we kind of make a splash where we go
and we got introduced one way or another and eventually I started working with
them and I saw what they were doing,
what they were doing here with the program and the pioneer and all these
different things,
these interesting things.
And at this point I started changing my,
my whole perspective around in mostly the biggest thing for me was I knew that
if I wanted,
I knew what I didn't want and I knew I had to get rid of criminality out of my
mindset.
And I knew I had to get stopped cutting corners.
And then like I said,
when I started working with Damien,
started getting introduced the idea that of human dignity.
So human dignity,
doing things in the right way,
it's not doing it.
I'm in a criminal way.
And from there my whole perception started changing on how I approach people,
how I approach situations.
Um,
how I identify options to solving challenges and problems finding,
seeking out mentors,
things like that.
So that's basically,
and it's,
it's still an ongoing process.
So it sounds like
the three of you spending time together as,
I mean maybe I'm taking it just got a one degree further than what I'm hearing,
but it seems like that's been important.
Absolute crucial.
Yeah,
absolutely.
Uh,
it's,
we're,
we're a team here.
We've kind of,
you know,
through all the things that we've been able to accomplish it on this facility,
we've been able to kind of form a community of sorts.
And it,
it's,
it's really a team effort upfront.
I know that for me,
you know,
even the whole change process,
it was a process,
uh,
by,
I had to first come to that realization that I can do better,
that I could be better.
Uh,
I had to accept it and I had to believe it.
And that's what we try to get guys to do on the facility,
on the yard is believe it.
You know,
believe in yourself.
Believe that you can be better,
you can do better.
You convince them of that?
It's like when you approach somebody for the first time a
choose the person you approach.
And then what do you say?
And I mean anybody can,
can hop in.
Uh,
it takes a,
one of the,
one of the things is,
is being in the right place at the right time.
Um,
we have self taught and picked up and question other people about everything
from effective communication techniques to ways of getting people over twisted
values.
I mean,
why do you guys do it?
Because I speaking for myself just because I'm a masochist and it needs to be
done.
Yeah.
Uh,
when I look out at some people,
uh,
here or anywhere else for that matter,
you watched the news,
you watch TV,
any of it.
It just sometimes feels like people are skin and bones,
you know,
there's,
they need some,
they need to be fleshed out a little.
And me too,
you know,
I'm,
I'm just as bad.
But I think that,
uh,
it's,
it's a communal thing everybody needs to be pitching in because nobody,
no man is an island.
Yeah.
Uh,
so we just need to be there.
We need to be available,
we need to be intentional.
We need to really try to help everybody elevate themselves because uh,
if we humanize everyone rehumanize ourselves and if we cut people down,
we're just cutting ourselves down too.
And it applies here in on steroids.
Well,
it seems like everything's magnified here.
It think things are a lot more intensified.
It's a lot more potent here,
at least in my opinion,
because everybody hears a little extreme in some ways.
Yeah.
You never know.
That's the thing.
You never know who it's going to be.
When the light bulbs going to click,
where it's going to go on you just one day we can be working on a guy for a
year,
just trying to have the right exchanges and interactions with them.
And one day he just gets it.
Or is it another guy we could think he's making progress and then something
happens and only have to come in and try to help him and see what happened.
What are some of the
approaches or expressions or concepts that you've seen help redirect people?
Like when you see people click,
and I,
if you could jump in on this,
I think,
I think the biggest thing,
and for me it's,
I've been there so I know what it feels like to not have hope and I have
purpose.
There are a lot of guys in here who are lacking those two things and I know
where it was like hope and purpose in there.
It's very,
very powerful.
Uh,
and that's what we try to give them.
You know,
we try to give them a dose of purpose,
you know,
uh,
whether it's through some sort of program or whether it's just on one on one
interaction,
which might the program look like.
Well,
just for example,
defy,
defy ventures has been amazing on this facility because it's,
it's a holistic,
a more holistic,
it takes a holistic approach.
It's not just entrepreneurship training,
it's,
it teaches character development.
It brings you closer to your family and it really gets you thinking about who
you are and who you can be most importantly.
And it's,
it's,
it's been hugely successful here because of it.
I would add into empowerment because I think a lot of the guys that we interact
with and myself included for a long time,
I just didn't recognize my potential or think that I really had any worth
investing in.
And I think that a lot of these guys feel that way.
And a big part of what we do is we engage that and we challenged them to look at
their potential and actually rise to it.
And I think that we do that to best that we can,
that we're currently able to do and we're trying to get better at it.
Thank you.
I think one of your,
I mean the standard approach,
like on the like institutionalized kind of formal level of any of these things
is your program that you would have defy,
um,
a,
any of these groups you have contents,
some sort of accredited content,
right?
So there's a curriculum,
there's a book,
there's a time honored,
there's 12 steps,
Oxford principles,
you have a dosage rate.
These guys will go to this group for x number of hours every week over a course
of a year.
That's x number of hours.
And then you have motivation and you get a result.
And the result could be something like 22% reduction in recidivism for substance
abuse,
something,
right?
Yeah.
The trick is the hard one to quantify is the motivation.
Right?
Right.
So that's where the hope and the purpose come in because a guy can sit in a
chair all day long.
A guy can answer questions on a worksheet all day long,
but unless he has the hope,
unless he has the need for a purpose,
unless he has the family begging him to get better,
unless he has his buddy that he's watched move on and is now,
it's like waiting for him to catch up.
Right.
You need to create this sense of people,
uh,
that you can rely on and that are relying on you in some sense and the
realization that you're part of a bigger community.
That sort of step in maturity,
that,
that growing up process because otherwise the entire formula,
it's just going to fall apart.
Yeah.
No,
it's so true.
I mean,
you can take,
you can take the content and shove it down someone's throat.
You can make them sit in the chair,
but if,
if they're mentally sort of teleporting to a different place,
and like you said,
the motivation is there just
because it's harder to quantify.
It doesn't make it any less important.
Exactly.
And that's why here,
especially on this facility,
uh,
you know,
we,
we say that time and again,
what we're trying to do here on this facility is we're trying to,
we're trying to create change,
but from the inside out rather than outside in,
because you can throw so many programs that people just,
like you said,
so much curriculum that,
you know,
half of it probably won't stick if that,
so it's,
it's a,
it's a process.
It's an internal process.
It's an individual process because,
you know,
just like out there in society,
everyone in here,
even though there are some commonalities,
everyone's different.
They've been through different experiences that have led them to be who they
are.
So it's,
uh,
it's hard work,
but it works.
Uh,
you know,
giving a person hope,
giving a person purpose.
Uh,
especially here,
we've,
we've been able to kind of track the progress of individuals who actually
participate in our rehabilitative programs,
educational programs.
Just like right now,
I can let you know,
I can tell you that if you participate in the program,
the inmates that participate in the program,
uh,
that person is three times less likely to receive a rules violation report than
someone who doesn't.
So it definitely does change something.
And if you look at the people who have,
uh,
as a,
I think Jason,
maybe you were mentioning some people you can deliver the sermon to,
right?
I mean,
you,
you communicate with and then they fall off the rails and that other people,
you work on them for a year,
you may be suspect they won't actually take to it and then they do.
Uh,
are there any patterns that you guys have seen in terms of say what,
what people fail to understand or pay attention to that leads them to fall off
the rails?
Is there any,
anything that really sticks out as a pattern where you're like,
man,
like dammit,
I like,
I should have seen it because we've seen this 17 times or four or 200 times
before.
I mean,
I don't know how many people you guys are communicating with because this is
what you have 1500 people or something like that.
And this we
have in this facility,
we can get up to 1000 by 1000,
but it averages at about 900,
you know,
give them give or take.
As far as pat,
I mean for my money and I can't speak for you guys,
right?
I mean everybody is really different.
Uh,
and that's kind of the reason,
at least for me,
um,
even if a guy lets me down 17 times out of 18,
that 18 time it might just click because I mean,
there are,
there are commonalities.
Usually the,
the impetus to change is something like a,
an event where his family shows up.
I've seen that a lot.
Um,
but some people,
there's like another group of people that I think just eventually they hit this
point where they're just tired and they just have this realization one late
night and they're just sitting there and they say,
I can't do this anymore.
And if you happen to show up at that moment,
I think you can lead them back into the light.
But if you're not there then in there,
then you probably missed your window.
So I'm not sure that it's like commonalities
in circumstances so much as it's these different circumstances lead to change.
And if you're lucky to get there,
you get there,
you know?
Uh,
cause it really is a time and place thing,
at least in my experience.
I,
I haven't personally,
uh,
identified any,
you know,
hard patterns.
I can't say that the times when I felt like it was starting to sink in is if I
was dealing with a guy who was constantly entertaining the wrong conversations
in the wrong company on the yard,
and you,
you can tell what you know.
And then suddenly I had this conversation with them and out of nowhere it's
really like a mature conversation and he's talking about wanting something
different and he's just talking to me about it.
And then the next time I see him,
he's actually acting on it.
That's a good indication that he's heading in the right direction.
And then it from there,
I think one of the things we've tried to implement is repeated exposure.
You know,
going back to that guy and going back to him and just work on,
on him,
encouraging them and open that he stays alone on the right path,
you know?
So I have a question for you just because you're,
you're mentioning you and your brother coming and people knew you guys were
coming and that you had,
uh,
some stature within this gang that you were once part of.
No,
no,
this is,
I mean I'm really curious about this because I've known people who have spent
time in prison,
some very,
very close friends of mine and uh,
people who've had all sorts of different types of
unhealthy coping behaviors,
but at a given point in time in their life,
some of those behaviors like served a purpose for them or they thought it did
right to escape from something or to survive something.
And uh,
what,
what I'm curious to,
and sometimes within that it's like you could throw it all out,
but maybe there's like a kernel of something that you developed that can be
applied in a good way.
Right.
It's what I'm really curious about it.
It's like you were,
sounds like had some type of leadership position or you were somewhat high in
the,
the pyramid and this gang.
Is there anything that you were good at then that is translated to you being
better at having these types of conversations or recruiting people to have,
recruiting is the wrong word,
but converting people to look at things differently.
Do you think there's any common ground there?
Networking.
Networking now I was good at networking and I'm generally good at people and
interacting with them generally.
Not always cause no one,
no one communicates perfectly all the time.
Right,
right.
But that's just one of the,
you know,
one of my strong suits.
Yeah.
What do you think,
and maybe these,
I mean these guys could comment on it also,
but like maybe it's easier from the outside looking in,
but like what makes you good at what do you,
what are some of the skills that make you,
or,
or approaches that make you better than most do you think could tell you what
makes Jason really good?
It's all right.
Here we go.
I'll,
I'll be [inaudible] I could see here like bright red.
It's okay.
I got you buddy.
Um,
so one of the things about Jason,
right?
I knew of Jason,
I never knew Jason until here and now I,
I know Jason,
but I knew of Jason before.
Um,
one of the things about Jason was that he was true to his word.
He had integrity,
right.
I'll give him that now.
What his word was at the time.
You know what that meant,
you know,
was,
I'm going to do something,
he's going to do it right.
Um,
that he's brought that with him though he has a very strong sense of integrity
and the values have changed with it.
Right?
So the thing about Jason is if he says he's going to show up to chat with you,
if he's going to show up to help you out,
if he's going to show up to give you a pep talk,
right.
He'll not only show up,
he'll probably give you a day and a time and then be up all night long if he
missed it and beating himself up about it and then drag one of us along with
them to make sure he gets into the building to talk to that guy the next day,
first opportunity.
Right.
And that's something that I think he was kind of known for before and now he's
being known for it again in a very good way because the new Jason is,
in my opinion,
a market improvement.
Very,
very disciplined.
Very dependent.
Yeah.
So the ability to keep promises.
But the,
the content of those promises,
this changed the values underlying Yang.
So my best work in progress.
So like where would you guys like to be say three years from now?
So I actually have the opportunity,
uh,
towards the end of the year to a transfer out to an mcrp,
which is a male community reentry program.
And what that is is I would basically serve the remainder of my term in a
facility on the streets wearing an ankle monitor and we're all where I'll have
the opportunity to actually a gain employment work and save towards that day
when I'm actually paroled.
Uh,
but in the meantime we are,
we actually started a podcast here on our facility,
Kern valley one 80.
I thought that's what we were doing right now.
That's what I thought too,
guys in our podcast.
It was supposed to be.
So,
you know,
in the knee with this first year coming up,
we,
we plan at least to kind of use that platform to not only show the guys in here
what it's like transitioning back out to society step by step,
but also kind of show society what it's like being in here and transitioning out
into,
into the community.
Uh,
for me at least,
I want to show the guy in here,
I want to show the guys,
look,
this is what I did while I was incarcerated,
while I was still behind the fence behind the wall.
And this is where I am now.
This,
these are the struggles,
these are difficulties,
the challenges that I'm facing.
So even though you're,
you can prepare yourself as much as,
as,
as you can,
if there are still going to be some challenges,
so you should prepare.
Absolutely.
So hopefully we're,
we're able to do that through the podcast and I,
you know,
in the next three years I,
I see myself heavily involved in some sort of organization that gives back to
this community
for sure.
Thank you.
Um,
well,
currently I'm serving life without parole.
So
I just hope that wherever I am at,
let's say a law changes and I'm somehow miraculously,
you know,
uh,
released to society,
then I hope to be doing something good with a rehabilitation in either way.
If I'm still incarcerated,
I'm hoping it'd be doing something that's meaningful towards rehabilitation and
the rehabilitation effort.
What do you,
what do you personally find most meaningful?
I mean,
this is really important concept,
right?
I mean,
it's really,
really important because I think as you guys have noted,
it's like without the,
without a purpose,
without the meaning,
it's very difficult to survive as a human in any environment.
But I think particularly in an environment like this.
So what,
what keeps you going and what would you say three years from now?
Let's say you're still inside,
what would make you look back with some pride on the,
the three years?
Well,
again,
anytime that you see the light go off for the guy who's been struggling,
the guy who is where I was,
you know?
Right.
And he starts taking control or more responsibility for his life and starts
learning tools to flourish and lead a stable and healthy life.
I think that's a win and if we can continue to get better and better at our
process of approaching it and helping more and more people,
that purpose for me.
So it's a good purpose in here,
sir.
I think so.
What,
what are,
are there any particular tools certainly defined and we're familiar with
defined.
I have a high opinion of the Pfizer.
Are there any other tools that you found helpful to
sort of as a,
this isn't the best term,
but like a gateway drug?
If you're trying to,
you know,
if you're trying to get somebody who's maybe not open and then they have that
dark night of the soul or their family visits and there's a window and you want
to offer them one thing to kind of nudge them towards a brighter path as a,
are there any,
do you have any favorites or anything that's particularly effective that you
found?
Well,
the most,
the thing that I think's been most,
most effective for me has been asking the right questions so that they can get
to the right answers.
And so if you're asking the right inquiry,
and Brad Munson,
pastor Krantz earlier,
he has a method of when we take a position on something,
he asks us questions to where our position is either exposed for being
vulnerable or being solid.
And I think that if you can do that in the right way to people,
then they are forced to come to their own conclusions about whether or not
they're coming from the wrong,
the right starting place or not.
And so whether that's a tool or a technique,
to me that's been a really effective thing.
Any any,
any questions you could share or a,
I don't want to keep you on the spot like anybody can answer this,
but like are there any particular questions that you guys use?
I,
I've obsessed over questions cause I really think that whether it's interacting
with someone else or interacting with yourself,
right?
Asking yourself the right questions which you guys are helping them to do.
So the pastor or a chaplain currencies,
a military man.
All right.
So he looks at things from that s a viewpoint a lot when it comes to developing
a,
an idea.
So we go to him,
you know the idea fairy lands on the shoulder and gives us some crackpot idea
and we go in there and we say,
Hey,
we've got this really great idea.
Let's do x,
Y,
z.
And he'll start running it through sort of a,
there'll be the practical questions,
there'll be the purpose driven questions.
There'll be,
you know,
who's going to run it,
where you're going to get the resources,
who's going to staff this?
What's the idea and then it will kind of segue into what are you trying to do?
What's the point?
Is what you're doing,
tackling a symptom is what you're doing.
Tackling the problem is what you're not a,
he'll really get into.
I mean it's a multilevel like systematic tear down.
Um,
stress tests stress that a few times we've surprised him.
But uh,
he also,
I think what you're also getting,
what Jason was also getting at is the sort of self leadership model too,
right?
So anytime something pops up,
you should be asking yourself the questions too so that you know where you
stand.
Otherwise it's too easy to knock you down.
So it's two fold.
You have to have asked yourself the questions.
Then once you have the idea in mind,
then you need to ask the questions about the idea and that if it stands up to
both those stress tests,
I think you're pretty good shape.
Uh,
at least considering a lot of the other stuff that goes on sometimes.
And for me it's,
it's,
it's a lot simpler really when it comes down to it,
I ask myself and I ask others,
is it the right thing to do?
Uh,
absent the environment,
the situation,
is that the right thing to do?
And that's basically what it boils down to.
You know,
with me it's,
you know,
it's,
is what I'm about to do the right thing is it,
is it right for me?
Is it right for everyone else involved?
And that's kind of the question that I always come up,
you know,
and ask somebody when I see they're getting ready to stray or they're getting
ready to make the wrong decisions.
It's,
is it the,
is it the right thing to do?
And if they,
they'd think that it is.
And I questioned them on it,
like,
why do you think that's the right thing?
And I just kind of try to lead them through that.
You know,
those logical steps.
Explain to me why you think putting that metal in,
that guy is the right thing to do because he called you a name.
It doesn't make sense at the end of the day.
And it's,
it's,
it's very,
very basic,
but people forget to ask that question sometimes.
Let me jump in on that because this is a,
you were talking about,
it's all relative,
right.
So if we get into like moral relativism,
one can almost argue that whatever they want to do is write,
write,
given whatever story or narrative they've built up for themselves.
Right.
So you had,
it was two counts of armed robbery II,
what I was convicted for?
Yes.
Yeah.
Okay.
All right guys.
So the list may be longer,
but that's the official,
yeah.
Uh,
at the time,
how,
why did you,
why did,
how would you've explained why you were doing those things?
I don't,
I could never justify what I did.
Uh,
but not now,
but like at the time,
how it was,
it was just a haze,
a cloud.
I was,
uh,
drinking heavily.
I was using,
I was using drugs heavily.
Uh,
I,
like I said before,
gravitated back to,
you know,
individuals that I used to,
I used to hang out with and I used to run with a gang.
Yeah.
And,
uh,
you know,
I just kind of,
I just reverted back to old ways that I had left behind.
And,
uh,
you know,
my judgment was,
was very clouded and I just kind of went with the flow,
which is what a lot of guys do in here.
They just go with the flow.
They assimilate this environment,
they suck it up.
And because it's prison,
everything,
every excuse you'll hear here is you'll,
you'll almost always here it's prison because it's prison,
because it's prison will just because it's prison,
it doesn't make it right.
And you know,
back then that's,
that's what it was.
Yeah.
It was just,
you know,
I wasn't in my right mind,
no clear judgment.
And so your judgment is,
seems clear.
Now,
what I'd love to hear from,
from any of you guys is
how you recall how you have recovered from slipping or relapsing or when you've
had the temptation,
what you've said to yourselves.
Right.
Because whether if like,
I know people who are drug addicts or former drug addicts,
alcoholics,
um,
my,
my best friend growing up,
unfortunately died of an overdose.
It's like I have not a lot of firsthand experience,
but I've,
I've watched even with,
let's just say on a very maybe mundane level,
people who are listening to this,
they have behaviors and they tried to change the behavior and maybe they succeed
for awhile and then they slip and maybe they slipped and they stay slipped for a
long time or not.
But like you guys seem pretty far on the other side at this point,
but could you talk about any times when you've either slipped and then had to
fix,
you know,
had to come back or had the temptation to slip?
I have,
I lead,
I think we got a bunch of time.
I gotta I gotta I got a sticky note here that says the bus broke down and we
have a delay so that their misfortunate is our good fortunate and I'm,
I'm afraid for them.
But still,
I,
uh,
I lead by example.
So you know,
when I,
when I feel,
when you know,
when the anger seems to get the best of me,
I always think,
you know,
if I lead by example,
what's that?
What's that going to say to that?
You know,
all the other guys.
And I'm like I said,
it's,
it's teamwork here,
you know,
with team.
Um,
I always try to keep that in mind really.
Right.
It's you sitting in an example,
whether it's good or bad.
Exactly.
And you know,
just not too long ago,
I lost my cool and it was,
it was kind of embarrassing.
You know,
we have,
one of them has been laughing here.
So let's tell us,
let's,
if we could talk about it,
let's talk about the details.
So I'm,
you know,
I'm,
I'm not now known as very levelheaded,
you know,
I keep my cool because I've kind of learned to do that.
Uh,
but you know,
here in prison we have all sorts of personalities,
all sorts of,
you know,
people with issues and whatnot.
And one of,
uh,
the worst happened to move in next door to me.
And,
uh,
look,
I'm programmer man.
I like getting out to my programs on time because you know,
half the time I'm standing in front of that room making sure the guys are,
you know,
heading in the direction they need ahead.
And,
and you know,
this particular individual decided to hold this tray because he,
he felt he didn't get enough food.
Um,
and obviously that turns into a problem because when he has holds his tray,
so he doesn't release this,
he doesn't really,
he doesn't,
uh,
he doesn't give up his trade through the port,
which means,
and now he has something solid that could be used as a weapon and obviously
that's a safety concern.
So for the time being,
they kind of,
we kind of close that section down,
you know,
pending that issue being resolved.
And that made me very upset.
But what made me even more upset was that when they try to reason with him,
you know,
and told them,
look,
if you continue doing this,
you're going to mess up the program for everybody else.
And the guy started yelling,
expletives out the door and basically cussed everybody out.
And here I am,
standing next door in full blues waiting to come out to run this program.
And this guy's over here crying about not having enough food and I kind of lost
it.
And he ended up giving up the tray.
AndW ,
you know,
we had some very unpleasant exchanges and I was pumped up and I was really,
really upset.
And I show up to this,
to the group and these guys are looking at me like,
what the hell happened to you?
And,
um,
it's the corner of his mouth.
He was,
it was.
Yeah,
it was,
it was bad.
I was getting,
uh,
you know,
I,
I felt emotionally I was ready to go there and I'm like to cross the line.
And then I took,
you know,
took,
took some deep breaths and I told myself,
you know what,
you have to practice what you preach,
men.
And I've done it before.
I've never allowed myself to go that for.
And,
um,
I had to humble myself.
You know,
when I came back in,
I went up to the guy's door fully expecting that door to open,
by the way.
And,
um,
I apologized and I said,
look man,
I don't know what the issue was.
If you didn't get enough food,
do you need,
do you need some?
It turns out the guy didn't have anything in his cell,
so maybe he was hungry.
He was kind of a big guy.
So,
you know,
I had to humble myself,
apologize and kind of,
you know,
a practice,
that effective communication that we always try to teach others here.
And,
uh,
it worked.
The situation was deescalated and you know,
the next morning he's like,
hey,
good morning buddy.
So I obviously I still keep kept an eye on him for the next week cause you know,
you never know,
but,
um,
it,
it turned out well and it's really,
it's just about practicing what I preach at the end of the day,
you know?
And,
and again,
leading,
leading through example,
and I can't,
how would that look if the guy who's preaching,
you know,
effective communication and resolving your conflict in other ways other than,
the physical way.
How would it look if I got into a fight,
you know,
in,
in the day room because,
you know,
the guy called me this and called me that and I went there.
It just wouldn't work.
Yeah,
we have the accountability.
absolutely.
Thank you know,
you guys,
I would repeat a lot of what Ian said.
I think that at this point we've made a lot of public statements about where we
stand on these types of issues.
So if we slip up on it,
it's a pretty big hit for one thing.
Secondly,
for me personally,
I have to always ask myself,
what's the outcome here?
And like how does this end and once it starts,
and so it's just trying to avoid the situation from the Gecko.
Now regarding a m a s a scrape of like a violent nature or something,
you can't,
you,
you can't possibly take in all the variables that could come with that.
Like anything could happen at any given time.
But I think that one thing I've tried to keep in mind is that every act that I
take,
I'm trying to reduce the possibility of that.
So every interaction,
I'm trying to keep it tore.
It doesn't even go in that direction.
Regarding substance abuse.
I've had a problem with that in the past.
And so again,
I've had people that are close to me that have a severe drug problem and it's
created a lot of anguish for me.
And at this point I think,
I dunno,
I've created enough mental leverage to stay away from it.
But if I ever am tempted again,
it comes back to what's my outcome here and what are the public statements I've
made and how much of a hypocrite will that make me,
you know,
so I just stay away from it,
period.
Thank you know,
ah,
man,
let's see.
I,
whereas there's the soft skill,
like there's the effective communication way of doing things and then there's
sort of like my way,
which is a,
not that all the time,
although I think I'm getting a little better.
Uh,
so I snap at people fairly regularly and have to go up afterwards and been like,
Hey,
my bad,
I suck.
Right.
Um,
as far as,
I've never particularly had a substance abuse problem,
uh,
myself.
Yeah.
And that's just an example,
right?
There are many different ways.
Yeah.
Slip.
I have an arguing problem and there are times when I get into that sort of
concrete thinking thing and even if I know I'm wrong,
I'm still going to argue my point.
I mean that's led to some beefs before.
Uh,
although I'm,
I'm trying to not do that anymore and that's where I'm kind of picking up from
these two guys over here.
How does,
how does your process or day change when you're trying not to do it?
Right?
So what do you do to I decrease the likelihood that,
you know,
I find that when I,
before I say things,
it tends to work a lot better.
And I know it sounds like kind of silly,
but that's,
I haven't often done that in the past,
although I have now.
So as long as I have sort of a mental checklist to run through and you know,
ask myself questions as we go and my thinking about this clearly,
do I understand what he's saying?
Is He,
are we clear on the terms that we clarified what the heck we're actually talking
about injecting a pause between the response.
Yeah,
exactly.
So as long as I take a breath before opening my mouth,
which is when I usually get in trouble,
um,
incidents on the yard kind of thing.
I mean there there's been times where,
uh,
there was the guy who clocked me in the face one day a yard and I had to walk
away from it and it was because of something he really news letter.
So it,
well,
let's dig into this.
So would you write in the news,
why do you punch you in the face?
And I don't know how much of this you'll have to be cut out or whatever.
We can always edit it later.
There was an incident that took place back in the vocational class,
um,
where a gentleman had gotten heated and somebody had to step in between it and
stop him.
And this incident led to a conversation later on,
right with him.
Uh,
cause well the guy who had gotten heated had hit the guy who stepped in between
him.
And the guy who had gotten hit,
which was another one of our pioneer newsletter guys,
another reporter or another editor or Madden,
uh,
editor.
Um,
so he had taken the hit and walked away and we applauded that.
We said,
hey,
look,
now you deescalate.
It it,
you,
you humbled yourself.
You took the head,
great job.
Um,
and now you have to remember in prison if you get hit and you don't hit back,
that's a bad thing according to prison standards,
that's precedent.
Somebody,
somebody had said,
well,
should you get hit in the face?
And you know,
people were just coming up and stealing your store,
right?
Your store is just a canteen.
You know,
your,
your hygiene,
your food.
And I had written this piece about yes,
because that's what we're going to have.
We're going to have roving gangs of marauders hijacking people in stage,
coach robberies for their store.
And I'd kind of made light of it.
Well,
the gentleman who had gotten heated way back in the beginning somehow
interpreted this as,
hey,
I was telling people to beat him up on yard and steal his store.
So he saw me at yard when I was out there reporting on a football tournament or
a soccer tournament and took a swing and he got me and I had just published,
I wanted to get them to buy.
I was seeing red,
my and my hackles were up,
but I was telling myself,
I was like,
dude,
you just wrote this thing about it's okay to walk away from taking a hit.
Don't worry about it.
You're not a bitch.
Right.
And I had done this whole thing and this guy cracked me.
I'm standing there and I had to take a breath and be like,
hey,
we're not doing this right here.
We're adults.
And I had to turn around and walk away.
Right?
Uh,
and everybody saw it and I was under,
I was getting the blues for a while,
but then slowly people were like,
yeah,
man,
don't worry about that guy.
It's cool.
It's the blues you were feeling.
I was just getting,
there were some people that were coming up and you know,
ribbon me and saying some pretty,
pretty hurtful things,
man.
But that's okay.
I'm used to that.
So,
so how did you,
how did you feel after that?
Were you proud that you did that,
where you were like,
man,
I should have ripped that fucking guy's face off?
No,
I was,
I felt bad that I had actually,
that I wrote something that he could interpret.
I should have gone and talked to him beforehand.
I should have been like,
hey dude,
we're going to write an article about something that happened involving you and
I should have been like,
is this cool?
And I didn't,
and that was my screw up and that made me feel bad.
And I actually went back and I had talked to the guy a few times and asked him
if he wanted to subscribe to the paper.
And uh,
that probably wasn't smart.
I thought I was giving him a peace offering and he just started kicking the door
and yelling at me.
So I had to walk away.
But I,
yeah,
I felt bad that I had,
I felt I'd handled it badly.
Yeah,
I'd walked away,
but I had allowed a situation to happen with this guy was mad enough to hit me.
And that was where I screwed up.
So I managed to not turn it into a big deal,
but I still EFT up in there somehow.
Where would,
where would you like to be in say three years time?
I mean,
if like three years from now looking back you're like,
yeah,
I did a really good job or I'm happy with my progress.
What would need to happen?
I can look at the yard I'm on three years from now and 51% of the people on that
yard.
I could be like,
yes,
these are grown up,
mature adults.
And I had some small part in that.
Uh,
if some program I helped run or come up with or bring to the yard or some sort
of stats that we had done to figure,
then I'd be like,
yeah,
I did a good job.
Uh,
because everything is to that end for me is making people kind of realize their
maturity
fists of 51% just meaning the majority.
Yeah.
I want to saturation rate.
That's,
you know,
51% then I know our product is a success.
So many different directions.
I could go with all this.
The first thing I probably should at least check off because I know some people
listening are going to be like,
wait,
they have a podcast.
So this is,
yes,
welcome to the Kern valley one 80 podcasts.
We're here with Tim Ferris.
Right.
Thank you for having me gentlemen.
Uh,
how,
how did that come to be and how do you guys record it?
And what do you talk about?
I mean,
you could I be,
so do you,
do you have,
you have gear that you have a room,
do you,
how does,
how does a podcast,
does it only get distributed among the people at the prison?
It is,
it,
is it more widely distributed?
So,
so
the leadership here is very progressive.
When CDCR said we're going to head more towards,
uh,
you know,
rehabilitation,
the administration,
the leadership really took that direction at heart and are following it.
Absolutely.
You know,
the idea came about,
uh,
I think there,
there's one,
there's another podcast on South San Quintin,
a lower level,
much lower level facility.
Uh,
and,
but,
you know,
the things that they talk about their,
and not,
you know,
talking smack about them,
it's more,
you know,
average day,
a daily occurrences on the prison yard type deal.
Uh,
here we're,
we're,
I think we're,
we're creating,
we're establishing more than just,
you know,
uh,
talking about canteen,
talking about the sports and the yard.
We're,
we're,
we're really trying to highlight that rehabilitation,
rehabilitation.
Um,
and,
you know,
we were approached by the administration if we would be interested in doing
something like that.
And we jumped at it.
Uh,
it turns out that this,
this,
uh,
this institution has a media room,
which it very,
it looks very much like a TV studio.
They have all the equipment and it's just kinda just kinda sits there because
they have no other use for it.
So,
uh,
you know,
they've,
they've allowed us to use that room for our podcasts.
We've been able to interview our warden,
which,
uh,
here is the first time that has happened.
You know,
inmates actually interview they're warning on a podcast and a we were able to
interview the CEO,
founder of defy ventures for example.
And you know we have a long list of of people and now we've interviewed you
cause that's what we're doing here.
So,
Oh yeah,
no we won't get to you guys are welcome to ask me it actually you guys got some,
anything you want the takes takes some responsibility off of my hands which I
like but first let me ask,
following up on something that I kind of pass by.
Is it,
is this widely available or is it only for people in the facilities?
We'll be,
once we record our finish,
our third one,
I believe it will be downloadable on iTunes.
I think it's great.
There's actually two versions of it here because like I said,
there's video cameras.
It's like a TV studio and there will be a like a video podcast version of it
available throughout the institution so that all the facilities here can,
can watch it and hear it.
And then out there for the public,
it will be what I,
what I believe,
just strictly audio podcasts through iTunes.
Yeah.
And you guys are welcome to use this audio man.
I'm happy to give you guys the audio too,
but you sounded like you had a question I wanted,
I wanted to ask you,
yeah.
Fire away.
What compelled you to come into a level four maximum security prison and sit
down with us?
Yeah.
Ask all these questions.
Uh,
I,
I think that it's very common whether it's inside or outside for people to
separate between us and them or me and others.
And when I look at,
for instance,
some of the people I grew up with who were my best friends,
like I mentioned,
one died of a fentanyl overdose.
Others have been imprisoned.
And just like you were saying,
there's this sometimes this almost magical positive window when someone sees
their family or has this dark night of the soul and there's an opportunity for
growth.
There are also these windows that open,
which are opportunities to make really terrible decisions and circumstances.
I'm not saying you don't have personal responsibility,
we're all responsible,
but at the same time I think it's,
uh,
I think it is wildly unreasonable for people to think that they could never find
themselves in a position if their life had been different,
if the,
if their surroundings and friends had been different,
where they would have made terrible decisions that could have landed them in a
place like this.
And so I think that my hope in coming here was a to just learn about new
environment and to get to meet people here.
Honestly.
I mean,
I just,
uh,
I'm very interested in learning as much as I can about like how,
what,
what does human nature look like inside the walls?
And not because these humans are necessarily intrinsically different from the
humans outside.
They've had,
they have very different stories.
But like,
what does it look like when like,
yeah,
you guys had mentioned when everything is intensified and magnified in a,
does that tell us perhaps something about ourselves more broadly speaking?
Right.
And,
uh,
also to,
um,
not to say that everyone here should be completely forgiven of all of the,
uh,
you know,
in some cases terrible things that they've done to other people.
But that I do think it's possible to have empathy for the humanity in each and
every person while still holding them accountable.
And that's,
that's,
I think that's one of our main goals on our podcast is,
look,
we're not trying to justify anyone's actions.
Anyone who's here,
you know,
what mistakes were clearly made.
But at the end of the day,
we want people out there to realize that people in here or just people,
yeah,
we're,
we're humans.
Uh,
you know,
we have that label,
prisoner or convict and you know,
and people sometimes tend to,
uh,
associate who we are strictly on the crime that we committed that maybe that bad
day,
maybe that bad decision,
maybe a series of bad decisions.
But at the end of the day,
we're,
we're human.
Like I've moved,
I'm here because I committed a crime.
And,
but I've moved past that.
It's,
I'm obviously reminded everyday when I wake up and I'm still in prison,
but I've been able to forgive myself and really worked on myself in order to
Sunday gain that forgiveness from my victims because there are victims and you
know,
I,
for me,
at least,
that's,
that's what we want to communicate out there.
Look,
we're just people,
anyone can make mistakes.
Sure.
There's degrees of mistakes,
but,
uh,
you know,
it's,
it's tough.
It's tough sometimes when you watch the shows on TVs and you hear the narrative
about prisoners and,
and it's just always all just a negative.
Yeah.
And the other,
another reason that I'm here is,
uh,
you know,
with,
with defy and really want to chat with you guys,
is
I'm fascinated by why people change,
whether it's for the better or for the worse,
or like what does that moment,
and what does that conversation,
what is the chaplain say to you or ask you write,
or what happens in the shoe?
Uh,
I'm really interested in these tipping points for people and liked to study them
because if you study them and you can then figure out like,
all right,
this particular tool works really well and it seems to work and you spot some
type of pattern.
I don't think that if we assume that human nature is human nature,
which I,
I suppose it's a bit of it like a Tautology,
but in the sense that the people inside are not that different from people
outside.
I think there's a lot to be learned in here that could also be applied outside
of here.
Right.
And uh,
I
not that I like the fact that everything is intensified here,
but it's,
it's in a way very similar.
I've spoken with Sebastian younger who was a war a will is considered by many to
be a war journalist,
but he's been deployed overseas and is his best friend was killed overseas with
a,
because it was a mortar round,
horrible tragedy.
And he's seen many people killed and in war either the,
the,
you also see the certain aspects of human nature that are just amplified.
Right.
And I think that gives you an opportunity to see things that you might not
otherwise see and learn.
Things you might not otherwise learn.
So,
uh,
but the fact that you guys have made,
made a series of bad decisions that have made a series of good decisions is very
interesting to me.
Right.
Um,
so that's part of the reason some of the reasons I'm here.
Yeah.
Um,
could I ask you a question?
Absolutely.
So one of the things that you do,
as you were saying,
you're trying to basically break it down,
they're trying to figure out what it is and makes a person tick.
Right?
So do you have goto questions?
Are you trying to get to the thought process?
Are you trying to get to what,
what is it that you're looking for when you're asking questions?
What process are you going through?
Yeah,
usually I am following my own curiosity.
Uh,
so if,
if,
if something,
if someone has experienced any type of sudden change,
I'm very interested in why that change took place.
So I'll explore that.
I might ask someone,
if you look back,
say at your business over the last five,
10 years,
uh,
you know,
were,
were there any specific decisions you made that you view in retrospect is really
critical?
Or was there anything you said no to that you were tempted to say yes to that
made all the difference,
right?
It,
was there something you were told you had to do that everyone told you you
should do,
that you decided not to do?
Was there anything like that?
Uh,
I like to explore the good decisions,
but I also really like to explore how people deal with a hardship and failure in
darkness.
Since I,
I've really tried to,
when I'm talking to anyone,
no matter how successful they may be,
like eight,
if I'm interviewing Richard Branson or interviewing,
it really doesn't matter.
Like any type of icon who might be thought of as this perfect superstar.
I know they're not.
No one's perfect.
And so I will ask them,
you know,
rather than just going through the highlight reel,
we'll talk about the highlights,
but I'll say like,
can you,
could you take us back?
People may listen to this and think that you've got it all figured out and that
you haven't had your tough times.
Like could you take us to a tough time or period that you suffered from
depression or where you thought it was all over and walk us through what you
said to yourself,
walk us through who helped you and how they helped you.
Like how did you get out of that funk?
I'm very interested in that.
Uh,
because uh,
I think those are the,
that is when some of the most critical decisions are made and it's like if
everything's lining up,
um,
it's really easy to be supportive of someone else or supportive of yourself.
But when things start going sideways,
when maybe you slip,
maybe you relapse,
maybe who knows,
you're paying too much attention to your business and you're not paying enough
attention to your kids and your kids make some really terrible decisions.
Like,
all right,
how do you,
we're all going to fuck up.
It's like,
all right,
how do you,
how do you then respond to that fuck up is more interesting then the question
have you fucked up?
Because the answer is obviously yes.
The more interesting question to me is like,
all right,
you fucked up now what happens?
And so
certainly in a different context,
but you know,
I've,
I've beaten myself,
hop horribly at my whole life.
I've had that very sort of a mixed relationship with myself and have had,
uh,
been very,
very,
uh,
brutal with myself just in terms of self talk for the majority of my life.
And I've only in the last few years realized how unproductive counterproductive
that can be.
And so the way in now,
externally,
if you're watching me respond to a mistake,
it might look the same as it did five years ago,
but what's going on in my head is very different.
Does that make sense?
Yeah.
And so what I tried to do then,
if I'm interviewing someone,
is to ask them to help me step into their head to see what's going on behind the
scenes or if they're afraid when they're most nervous,
right?
If their,
if their championship fighter and they're getting ready for the biggest fight of
their life.
Like what are they saying in their head as they're walking out to the octagon
months of training and like their entire careers on the line.
And they could,
they could have their head caved in.
Like what are they actually saying in their own head when they're listening to
their music,
walking out the,
these are the types of questions that I've been exploring more and more in the
last few years because I think that you can,
you can learn from a real fighter like say,
you know,
Tim Kennedy also Greenbury sniper.
I mean,
just an incredible guy.
You can take lessons from him and apply it to business.
You can take lessons from business and apply it to military.
In some cases.
You can take lessons from chess and apply it to working with people in the yard,
I'm sure,
uh,
in some cases and vice versa.
Uh,
perhaps.
So,
uh,
usually I'm digging for the internal process and trying to find phrases or
questions or concepts that can be applied to a lot of different things.
Uh,
that's very often what I'm,
what I'm looking for.
Uh,
yeah,
yeah.
That,
that's,
that'd be my first stab at it.
Okay.
Something like that.
And also the unit to dig out the humanity in someone.
So it's,
uh,
to encourage people to be vulnerable when they can be a,
or to like push to a point where they're at least a little uncomfortable.
I think that's when interesting things happen.
Uh,
not in the sense of pushing yourself closer to say a red line situation.
Not,
not pushing in that direction,
but,
uh,
you know,
I remember interviewing this woman named Bernais Brown who's a researcher and
she's,
she studied a lot related to shame and vulnerability and related topics.
And,
uh,
she said something to me that a really big impact.
She said,
we often,
and I'm paraphrasing,
but she said very often we,
we think that we need to develop trust with someone and then we can be
vulnerable.
And she said,
but very often it's the opposite way around.
You have to be vulnerable first before someone will trust you.
And that really stuck with me.
Uh,
and,
uh,
in any case,
but,
but I'm trying to find some of the connective tissue and these commonalities
that can apply anywhere.
Right.
And it's like if humans are humans,
which by and large,
I think it's certainly the case,
and like,
whether you go to the middle of nowhere in the jungles of Borneo or you're in
New York City or you're in here,
or you're anywhere else,
like the same type of pain,
the same need for purpose and meaning.
Like it's,
it's all there.
It's,
it's universal.
So I,
I try to tease out hopefully things that people can apply in any of those
contexts.
Thank you.
Yeah,
of course.
Uh,
well,
let's see.
You know,
I'm struggling with,
uh,
I think this is a pretty natural place to start to maybe wrap up a bit,
but,
uh,
do you guys have anything that you would like to ask or say to people who were
listening?
Maybe not ask,
but as I said before,
earlier,
uh,
my change came through,
really education,
it really opened my eyes.
I,
credit wise I have enough college credits or I have the equal amount of credits
that someone halfway through their masters would have.
Um,
but I,
I can't achieve that because there is no funding for postsecondary four year
graduate degree levels.
So,
you know,
I'm hoping that
some legislation will gain some traction that would give the opportunity for
individuals in our circumstances to,
you know,
apply themselves and earn,
a higher degrees.
Uh,
I would just say,
uh,
I guess it's kind of an ask w it would be something like,
you know,
please don't write us off in prison.
Uh,
we've made some really,
really bad choices.
Absolutely.
And we are responsible and we are accountable for those and nothing can take
them back.
But that doesn't mean that we can't change and do better.
And I think a lot of times from what you see on TV and what you hear about most
often,
hard time lock up shows like that,
it's kind of painted in the light that there's no hope for people in here.
And that's really not the case.
We see it.
I hope that you come to see it.
I hope people listening will hear it and just don't give up on people inside
prison.
Um,
if I could say anything to anyone out there,
it would be that I find myself now in a place where I actually have meaning in
my life and I feel like I'm bringing value to other people,
but that's mostly because of my community in here and because of my family and
friends on the streets who never gave up.
So for anybody who has someone in their life that's struggling,
I would just say don't give up on them,
hold them accountable,
but continue to give them hope and try to provide them tools and opportunities
to where they can make a change and start making some good decisions because you
just never know
who that person can really become.
So just don't give up.
Thank you guys.
Thank you.
Yeah,
I mean on the inside or the outside.
Right.
I think those are good rules,
good recommendations.
And,
uh,
it's,
um,
but I consider it a real privilege to,
to share time with you guys because I mean if I think about it,
right,
I mean you have the opportunity potentially.
It's like if you build up
a
to get to that 51% potentially right and beyond.
But if you have,
if you develop
this
your own program of sorts and you have your approach to helping people
develop this meaning and this hope and also tilt just slightly in the positive
direction in a more positive direction,
it doesn't have to be.
And they become mother Theresa overnight,
which is pretty unlikely.
But just like one degree better write that one degree.
It's like you start off here and you,
if you change your position walking say one or five degrees in a different
direction,
like you walk 10 feet,
it doesn't seem like that far away.
You walk a hundred feet,
okay,
now,
now it's quite a bit of a distance away.
And then he walked a few miles.
Now it's completely different destinations.
Right?
And so that initial change can,
can make it make a huge difference ultimately.
And it strikes me that like,
well after you guys have left this place,
uh,
you could leave a legacy of people who continue to do that and potentially
right.
And so that's the goal,
right?
And see if kind of like senior class teaches the junior class,
he just a sophomore class and that,
I mean,
that's a really meaningful legacy.
So Warner's there's no alumni are coming back,
so as long as long as there are no alumni reunions,
the graduation.
Right.
Uh,
well guys,
I really appreciate you taking the time and uh,
I certainly wish you all the best with everything that you're working to build
and you know,
inside yourselves and outside and keep,
keep it up with the podcast.
Thank you for coming on the Kern valley one 80 podcasts.
We're your hosts
and good luck on your podcast.
Sure.
It'll take off one day on the,
here you could be white Gus with tens of hours of experience strangling a little
bit out there.
Now that you've got the big interview out of the way.
That's right.
Food in the room is gone.
So,
uh,
I think we should get back to get back to the excitement across the yard.
So,
uh,
you guys want to give your names one more time.
Jason Holland,
e And v Tutorial,
which you forget for a second.
I'm sorry,
I have to disclose right,
my [inaudible].
My name is [inaudible],
but it's so strange and odd that everyone just calls me Ian [inaudible] via
tutorial,
but it's via guitar and I'm Brandon Menard.
Alright,
gentlemen,
thank you so much and keep it up.
Thank you to hey guys,
this is Tim again.
Just a few more things before you take off.
Number one.
This is five bullet Friday.
Do you,
you
want to get a short email from me?
Would you enjoy getting a short email from me every Friday that provides a
little more soul of fun before the weekend and five bullet Friday is a very
short email where I share the coolest things I've found or that I've been
pondering over the week.
That could include favorite new albums that I've discovered.
It could include Gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of weird shit that I've
somehow dug up in the,
uh,
the world of the esoteric as I do.
It could include favorite articles that I've read and that I've shared with my
close friends,
for instance.
And it's very short.
It's just a little tiny bite of goodness before you head off for the weekend.
So if you want to receive that,
check it out.
Just go to four hour work week.com.
That's four hour workweek.com all spelled out and just drop in your email and
you will get the very next one if you sign up.
I hope you enjoy it.
This episode is brought to you by business wars.
People always ask me what podcasts I listened to.
And the truth is not many because given all my other projects,
I don't have a ton of extra bandwidth.
But one new addition is business wars from the podcast network wondering,
human history has seen hundreds upon hundreds of epic wars,
of course,
and often they're between nations,
but some wars are waged between large corporations are between startups and the
large incumbents.
Business wars which have been listening to teach you right into the middle of
these battles that are waged for control of your wallet and your attention
ranging from say the wars between Netflix and blockbuster or a Nike and Adidas,
two rivals and small businesses across the country struggling to survive in a
cutthroat world.
These stories really feel like dramatic thrillers.
I've been very impressed by the sound design also,
which I didn't think I would care about,
but it makes a huge,
huge difference.
And just to give you an idea of what you might discover,
did you know that blockbuster was actually catching up with Netflix until
corporate rater?
Carl ICAHN got involved and did that episode is a fantastic one.
It's called sudden death.
It's the first episode in a multipart series that looks at blockbuster and
Netflix,
which I'm particularly interested in because it's not just two businesses and a
stagnant industry with stagnant technology.
There's a lot of different factors that come into play or did you know or do you
know what marvel did to really get ahead of it's much larger competitor?
DC comics.
Great interest to me since I was a comic book nerd and collected comics when I
was a kid or how sneakers went from athletic work everyday where this series
explores all of that and more.
It's hosted by David Brown,
a former anchor of marketplace,
and it is an immersive sound design experience and not just some type of sterile
business review that shares the untold and very real stories of what went on
behind the scenes with the leaders,
investors,
executives that led them to either new heights or to roof.
Sometimes somewhere in between you can search business words on apple podcasts
or wherever you're listening to this episode right now or had to Wondery dot f m
Ford Slash Tim,
that's w o n d e r y.fm forward slash Tim to find business where it's a great
show and I do not say that lightly and I might suggest start with sudden death,
Netflix versus blockbuster.
This episode is brought to you by helix sleep.
Last year,
I committed to making sleep a top priority,
trying to fix onset insomnia or continuing to fix that depth of sleep,
quality of sleep.
I tracked a lot.
I tested a lot and I revisited really everything from daily routine to the
surfaces.
I slept on playing with the chilly pad,
whatever,
and I moved to Austin.
I got all new beds including mattresses from Helix,
working with the world's leading sleep experts.
Certainly some of them,
he looks sleepy at all mattresses.
Personalized to your preferences and sleep style to make sure that you can have
the best sleep possible without costing thousands upon thousands of dollars.
He looked.
Sleep has recently added a new layer,
customized sleep with the helix pillow.
Y'all new pillows are fully adjustable so you can achieve perfect comfort
regardless of sleep position or body type or if you're a shifty type like May.
I move around quite a bit when I sleep.
Just take their simple two to three minutes sleep quiz to get started and that
will help ensure that they can build a mattress or pillow that you will love the
mattress,
whatever this be spoke mattress is that you arrive at,
uh,
we'll get to you within a week and the shipping is completely free.
You can try the mattress for 100 nights and if you're not completely happy,
they'll pick it up and offer a full refund.
I tested that refund policy because I test all of these sponsors and kick the
tires a lot.
We tested it and they came through and making sure that we got ultimately the
right mattress for my body.
Type to personalize your sleep experience,
visit Helix,
sleep.com forward slash Tim and you'll receive up to $125 off your mattress
order.
That's helix sleep,
h,
e l I x sleep.com forward slash Tim for up to $125 off your order.